hey what's up Billy is that spite let me
pick this off so I can see you better
hold on let's see if you weren't already
get ready to be a proud card-carrying
member of the Tom Holland fan club
because he just pulled off the cutest
surprise and our hearts are literally
melting happy birthday say thanks to
spider-man Thank You spider-man the
spider-man star appeared on Jimmy Kimmel
Live Tuesday chatting with a late-night
host via video chat from his home in
London well I have a favor to ask of you
that's when Jimmy told Tom it was his
son Billy's third birthday and their
plans to throw him a spider-man themes
bday bash were totally squashed due to
the coronavirus we watch ok both of your
spider-man movies over and over and over
again and we'd promised him that
spider-man would the real spider-man
would come to his party now of course
we're just gonna hire a guy in a in a
suit but now nobody's coming to his
party his party is just us and I was
wondering if you'd say hello to him I
can't guarantee you he's gonna register
but would you mind absolutely no trouble
at all all right brace yourself guys
because Tom straight-up breaks the cute
leader who did I say was gonna come to
your birthday party who did we say was
gonna come to your birthday party buddy
the real spider-man I want you to say hi
to somebody all right let's see who's on
the screen does that guy look familiar
to you is that spike let me pick this
off so I can see you better hold on
let's see yeah okay no wait Jimmy's
daughter Jane straight-up brakes the
cute meter that is Peter Parker hey
Billy how you doing Wow can you believe
I am is Peter Parker I live in Queens
New York where do you live you know we
left California can you even handle that
and then Tom putting on his American
accent and getting
right back into character yeah
absolutely
Jane did he what did you say about Peter
Parker's face yeah it's cute face he she
said you have a cute face thank you so
much I appreciate that that's very tiny
yep Jimmy did what dads do best
absolutely mortified his daughter are
you mad at me for saying that
oh no but he likes it nice well and this
surprise ended with a birthday song for
Billy
happy birthday Thank You spider-man say
thanks to spider-man Thank You thanks
[Music]